i knew from my experience in the other
men in black films that we kind of would
tend to over build things we would
build aliens so you could do anything
with them and then when you'd seen the
final movie they're a blur in the
background or it's a shot that goes by
like this and that was something that
was so great when when i heard that ken
ralston was going to do this film is
because i've known ken for a really long
time you know i i said to ken
i would like to build more aliens and
not put the
effort into putting eye blinks and
things into them because they're
probably not going to show up anyways
and
if they in fact do show up and they're
featured in a scene can you put the eye
blinks on and he said what did you say
no
i mean we've known each other since i
guess who were like 17 something like
that believe it or not and this really
was the first film even though we sort
of were involved
but barely on rocketeer
but in star wars too we've been star
wars
was that about your space thing yeah
that was a long time ago
but uh you know it was was sort of in
that way but this way was a lot more
connected and more integrated with the
two of us it was a lot of fun it was
great to work with rick the thing that i
really liked about it was
that i don't forget what version i read
but the the one i read had so many
different things like you see in the
movie there's so much variety of of the
type of work that's required the
challenges that are in it that it really
excited me about that variety because
every day if you're doing a one-trick
pony show and that's all you're doing
and you get really boring and this had a
lot of fun stuff to do because the film
obviously isn't trying to be serious
it's pretty funny and and you could do a
lot of weird stuff in this film we
couldn't do on certain other types of
movies so that's what i liked about i
liked how much different work we were
able to do
keeps the crew excited keeps everyone on
their toes and it makes a lot of fun um
you know when we're on set ideally we
want to get as much in camera as we
possibly can
but when you go into a production with
script that's kind of changing and has a
lot of ideas around it you
end up thinking far into the future or
trying to imagine what could possibly
come our way
and trying to it's like trying to plan
for everything and so a lot of those
decisions we may ken and i may discuss
and with barry and with rick and with
every other department on the show to
discuss exactly how we're going to do it
or how we want to do it
and then on the day something new comes
up on set so give me some duct tape yeah
exactly so it today you know example of
the monocycle sequence changed a lot
uh during the production and it changed
all the way throughout post as well so
we used every technique we could come up
with it seems like and then some we
couldn't come up with it felt like to
make that stuff work so it's a lot of
planning but a lot of stuff changes
during the process and the the lines
between
pre-production shooting and
post-production are really just getting
blurrier and blurrier as we go you know
it was harder on the first movie because
we didn't really know what men in black
was and that and that was the thing i
kept saying is it a comedy is it serious
do i make
scary aliens do i you know make
realistic aliens do i make comedy aliens
and
and it took us a while to figure that
out on the first one it's definitely
easier now you know than that we knew
and we know what men in black is you
know but uh
but it's always you know i would
for example with boris when i wanted to
make him what he was you know
they kept saying well
it's too scary it's too scary and i kept
saying well you remember the first movie
edgar in the first movie i said that's
you know you could put him in a horror
movie and
and edgar was a cool villain and he
worked i said the second movie we had
serena
and that didn't work you know i go let's
err on the side of being ignorant i said
you know in this whole thing with the
weasel and coming out of his
palm and stuff was something i kind of
conceived of when they originally in the
script it said
there there was this carrot they this
thing inside the cake but it turned into
a gun and and and became boris's gun
and i kept saying
that doesn't make sense and they kept
saying well you know it's like it's like
the transformers and they go no it isn't
you know
transformers is a machine turning into
another machine you know you're talking
about an organic creature turning into a
gun you know
yeah uh you know but it's uh it evolved
into this thing that was kind of cool
and i and i said you know i think it
should originally had it clamped onto
his arm like a weird piece of jewelry
and then we started thinking about it
and it's like every shot to have this
thing on there would be kind of weird so
i thought well let's have him crawl
inside you know and
and then they go it's going to be kind
of creepy and it's like
but kids kids will love it you know it's
something they're going to talk about